comment allez vous en attendant 2008
avec 7,1 trop écouté les amis
aujourd'hui je suis tout excité pourquoi
parce que hier j'ai reçu un mail d'un
abonné me conseillant le site greg craig
je savais que j'allais avoir du mal à
dire craig's list [ __ ] c'est sur le
site craigslist qu'est ce que ces 500 go
entre le bon coin vivastreet
rueducommerce bref il ya un peu de tout
en gros c'est des annonces mais ça peut
concerner tout et n'importe quoi il ya
une partie best-of sur crysis qui
regroupe les annonces les plus
improbables qui assure le site
et vu que c'est un site qui est
essentiellement utilisée aux états unis
en france et plus le bon coin et bas
comme vous le savez aux etats unis ils
font tous un plus grand plus gros plus
large plus plus loin dans le délire donc
les annonces avec un peu pareil c'est en
anglais au montage bien évidemment on
traduire en français pour votre plus
grand plaisir moi je vais faire
l'interprète de qualité que vous l'avez
dans la dernière vidéo du couple la
moitié de la jambe d'une araignée
combien de jambes
va-t-il rester à l'araignée je sais
parfaitement lire tout ce qui est en
anglais alors premièrement une
profession une entraîneuse
professionnels de pokémon go 20 dollars
leur bec c'est archi cher c'est
incroyable à propos de moi j'ai 24 ans
et j'adore pokémon et je veux vous aider
vous à devenir le meilleur dresseur
fantastique
personnellement je suis un entraîneur de
niveau 15 dans pokémon go cellule on
cultive aucun choix
j'ai actuellement un iphone 6 aces
plusieurs chargeurs de portables et je
suis en très bonne forme physiquement
marché plusieurs heures n'est pas un
problème je me connecte au ray avec
votre compte et je ferai comme si c'est
le mien je les attrape rêves tous chaque
échange débutera par une consultation au
poker top le plus proche
mais c'est génial comme rendez vous je
sais comment me défendre donc pas de
bullshit avec moi [ __ ] m'appelle met
les points sur les i écoute heavy steve
quand tu veux je te file mon téléphone
est vraiment pour 20 $ l'heure en plus
c'est vraiment rentables ces attaques et
bien ça veut dire qu'en trois heures
j'aurais pu m'acheter de pokémon soleil
sur ma ds et jouer sans avoir à bouger
de chez moi en plus c'est bon c'est
mignon alors une vieille poupée
allemande des années 1800 au mexique
loquace fuck c'est quoi ce délire j'ai
vu la poupée annabelle en vrai y'a pas
longtemps mais je vous jure qu'à côté de
ça annabelle mais qu elle était gentille
tu invites au resto sans aucun problème
mais j'ai jamais vu une poupée aussi
creepy sa mère mais attends ça quoi
c'est un bol en fait derrière son crâne
ce matin pour manger des céréales sans
déconner [ __ ] mais de la description
il ose dire joli visage quoi match
désolé mais ça c'est pas du tout un joli
visage c'est un visage qui va tenter
pendant de nombreuses années l'arrière
de la tête est endommagée a donc c'est
pas normal ça je sais pas quel enfant
elle a eu entre les mains mais c'est un
but en psychopathe
gage et m'a mis mal cet homme vend 99
bouteilles de bière vides
voilà mais il a la gentillesse nous dira
que ça peut servir j'ai collectionné 99
bouteilles de bière unique ces dernières
années mais j'ai finalement atteint mon
but et je suis prêt à passer à autre
chose
les faire recycler ou les confier à une
bonne personne si vous planifiez un
voyage au michigan et que vous voulez
obtenir un taux de rendement incroyable
de 9,90 dollars sur votre investissement
de recyclage c'est l'offre qu'il vous
faut mais si j'en tue soir et pense à
nous atchia pas comme tu gagnes tu
pouvais russie clé une bouteille vide de
bière et on file et 10 centimes
bon là c'est une info peu utiles elles
font de très bonnes munitions pour les
combats dans les bars je vous le
confirme
elle se casse très facilement comme des
bouteilles normale et vous pouvez
parfaitement frappé la tête de quelqu'un
avec notes en vrai ne le fait pas il est
génial ce mec est génial jamais dû
acheter mais qu il est si fort qu'on a
envie de lui acheter ses bouteilles de
bière vides c'est fou pète spyder qu'est
ce que c'est que ça je cherche une
nouvelle maison pour ma petite araignée
elle a récemment perdu son ami elle se
retrouve seule et dépressive elle est
facile à garder est très silencieuse je
la donnerai seulement à une personne
tarif
envoyez moi sourit parce que quand il te
dit elle a perdu son ami elle est seule
et dépressive [ __ ] j'ai envie de rire
alors que c'est horrible quoi ça c'est
vrai à elle est mignonne non plus à
aller au [ __ ] elle fait part hier
c'est grand olala oui oui ça dégage
c'est nul à chier comme objet overboard
kart wii line man show à temps sinon
ouais je dirai ce que je vais dire mais
qui sait gaver il a fait un [ __ ] très
doux avec un hoverboard alain fernex un
butin d'ingénieurs tu t'assois là et a
même une petite place pour un sac
derrière ou une glacière mais je me
déplaçais dans ce véhicule
ce kart scooter unique est
impressionnant et sûr d'attirer
l'attention mais clairement vraiment
utiliser le pour naviguer vers votre
trou de pêche ou votre camping préféré
sans avoir à trimballer tout votre
matériel je veux l'acheter prenait
battue je veux aller au bureau avec ça
mec je suis scotché une potée tôt il
vend une [ __ ] de patates
il l'a laissée coyotes en jardin c'est
un scandale vue pendant mon nettoyage de
printemps je nettoyais une armoire et
j'ai trouvé à l'arrière une patate
je me suis senti triste de la retirer de
la parce qu'elle a fait une telle preuve
de combativité
si vous avez une cour ou un jardin et
que vous seriez prêts à prendre soin de
cette patate contactez moi j'espère que
vous serez capable de lui fournir une
grande maison aimante et un sol fertile
à cultive
les gens ils ont l'art de vendre des
choses des tout nul il a fait un si beau
discours j'ai envie d'adopter cette
patate sûr mais je me suis trompé en
allant chercher natsu japon mais il y
avait tout aussi mignon pas loin quoi
alors oh là là ça va être creepy ça oh
arrêtez avec vous avez des poupées pour
20 trilogue haut mais qu'elles sont
crypte il faut vraiment arrêter c'est de
pire en pire chaque nouvelle photo est
pire que la précédente
oh là là regardez le lui dirai qu'il est
pas sur la photo de base je suis le mec
la boule un poteau avril a fait mais
j'ai pas et pouvaient que ce qu'elle
fait là il me dit quoi le mec fait vos
offres je les échange contre des vieux
trucs godzilla des lunch box des
guitares ou à peu près tout ce que vous
avez un x wing fait maison
mais qui s'est trouvé mon fils s'est
cassé la jambe et a dû est en fauteuil
roulant pendant plusieurs semaines y
compris celles d'halloween
assez pour ça j'ai fait un simple x wing
qui se posent sur la chaise roulante
mais qu'un simple x-wing lui on n'a pas
la même notion de simples si quelqu'un a
un fils en chaise roulante qui serait
intéressé pour récupérer le x wing vous
êtes le bienvenu c'est officiellement le
meilleur papa de l'univers il ya plus de
doute un nom encore une poupée dégage on
peut plus non vraiment au nom cyclo
cross et que l'horaire la photo qui
pointent on sait s'il en train de faire
oh là là ça fait rêver qui de rentrer
demain c'est sur son canapé
j'ai laissé deux personnes montrer la
poupée un de leurs amis ils ne sont
jamais revenus à la base cette poupée
devait être la mascotte de mon groupe de
post grunge rapport de police a été
déposé les mecs ont volé une poupée
sexuelle c'est vraiment un délire
étrange
ouais par contre avec la poupée à cinq
mille balles oui mais c'était la
mascotte de mon groupe de rock oui oui
oui t'as juste eu extrêmement honteux
quand à elle te plaindre auprès des
flics que tu fais voler ta poupée
sexuelle
on connaît bien la douille alors un
camion camouflé pour 1800 dollars
j'aimerais bien voir ça mec champ mais
quatre roues motrices intérieur 9
fenêtres bien nettoyer très peu de
kilomètres au compteur
on achète ok là on est tombé sur un gros
a dit qu'ils vont juste un emballages
vides de toilette avec la photo de
toilette sur le devant et j imagine et
l'excitation des enfants en voyant un
cadeau si gros sous le sapin
rien ne vaut à la fois un tel souvenir
et traumatisme de toute évidence je
ferai un jour des blagues à mes enfants
ok y'a un mec qui propose un service
très particulier pour cent à leur part
je viendrai m'assois à votre fête à
l'endroit de votre choix je regarderai
vos invités pendant toute la durée de
l'événement merci et bonne fête
je vous savez qu'ici je me dis ce
matelas et pour tout la vidéo il regarde
la caméra avec levé devant un matelas
dans lequel il a fait un trou parce que
sa femme était enceinte et du coup elle
pouvait plus dormir sur le ventre il a
trouvé son [ __ ] de matelas pour que le
vent 32 dents et maintenant que sa femme
a accouché il vend le matelas parce
qu'il s'appelle horaire c'est génial
late breaking frisbee et cela est cette
merde assez une offre juste pour jour
frisbee avec lui peu importe de quelle
race ou de quel genre vous êtes j'essaie
pas de racketter ou de violet quiconque
tue tout ce que je veux c'est que vous
envoyez un [ __ ] de frisbee et vous me
l'envoyer en retour et oui je suis très
très fort aux lancers et à la réception
de frisbee mais ne soyez pas intimider
let's do this shit
[Musique]
mais que tu ai vus j'ai envie de faire
office d avec ce mec est bien des amis
c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur les
meilleures annonces de craiglist c'était
très amusant
n'hésitez pas l'aimer ciel vous a plus
et j'adore trouvé c'est comme les même
si on a gagné tous ces trucs là des fois
j'adore juste me poser pendant deux
heures et juste observer l'ingéniosité
ou la connerie des gens ça n'apporterait
rien je tue le temps en faisant ça mais
[ __ ] des fois qu'est ce que je trouve
ça marrant et aux us les mecs sont
perchés sur dans un game futur quoi je
vous dis à bientôt dans une prochaine
vidéo
oui c'est la fin du tournage je suis
content lucas enfin tu t'occupes de moi
allez bientôt
[Musique]